These days, you'd be a fool to leave a movie
theatre before the credits finish rolling
at the end of any given movie.
Why?
Well, because there's every chance that you'd
be missing out on one or more additional scenes
that could appear in or after said credits.Although
such scenes have existed for many years, these
days they are commonplace - and they can be
very important.
They can include fun Easter eggs, hint at
things to come in the future of a franchise,
unravel mysteries from within the movie you
just watched, or simply extend the story of
the same movie.For a variety of reasons, certain
scenes of this nature have been extremely
prevalent in the history of movie-making.
This video will take a look at some great
examples.
Here are the ten movies with game changing
post credit scenes scenes.
Iron Man
As far as comic book movies are concerned,
there was no bigger game-changer than Iron
Man in terms of its post-credits scene.
After Robert Downey, Jr.'s Tony Stark had
revealed himself to the world as the tituar
armoured hero, the credits rolled before Samuel
L. Jackson's Nick Fury turned up in Stark's
house to talk to him about the Avenger Initiative.
That was back in 2008 and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is still going strong.
It was Iron Man's post-credit scene that triggered
the expansion of the entire franchise and
let audiences know that there was a hell of
a lot more to expect from the MCU - such as
the assembling of the Avengers.
The Avengers
When it comes to "wow" moments in credits
scenes, none were more prevalent than the
one fans were given in the middle of the credits
of The Avengers.
The main villain of the movie was Tom Hiddleston's
Loki.
He had been aided by Alexis Denisof's mysterious
"The Other" and the Chitauri army, but there
had been hints about a more powerful being
commanding them.
In the mid-credits scene of The Avengers,
that being was revealed to be none other than
the Mad Titan Thanos.
It was at that moment that fans of the MCU
were made aware that he would be the big-bad
of the franchise - and that things were going
to get crazy as a result.
Thanos has since appeared in Guardians of
the Galaxy and in the mid-credits scene of
Avengers: Age of Ultron - but he'll truly
make his presence felt in the upcoming Avengers:
Infinity War movies.
Of course, there was also a scene after the
credits, in which the Avengers were seen eating
shawarma - a fun and unusual reference to
a line Tony Stark had spoken earlier in the
movie.
Captain America: Civil War
The single biggest movie event in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to date has been Captain
America: Civil War.
The movie saw two factions of comic book heroes
fighting each other on the big screen for
the first time and was a huge success both
critically and commercially.
Of course, that meant the credits scenes had
to be great - and both of the certainly delivered.
Both Black Panther and Spider-Man were introduced
in Civil War and the two credits scenes led
into their upcoming solo movies.
Audiences were given a first glimpse of the
spectacular fictional country of Wakanda,
while Tom Holland's Peter Parker was shown
at home playing with a high-tech Spider-gadget,
suggesting that Spider-Man will be utilising
Stark-tech in the franchise going forward
- an exciting prospect indeed.
Napoleon Dynamite
The post-credits sequence of the brilliantly
funny and quirky Napoleon Dynamite is a full
five minute scene that concludes a sub-plot
from the movie itself - the marriage of Napoleon's
brother Kip and LaFawnduh, played by Aaron
Ruell and Shondrella Avery respectively.
The scene shows the pair exchanging nuptial
vows in an outdoor ceremony in Preston, Idaho.
Jon Heder's Napoleon arrives late, riding
a horse, claiming that it is a "wild honeymoon
stallion" that he has tamed himself.
Kip then flicks LaFawnduh's garter as a "keepsake"
towards Napoleon, Rico, and Pedro, before
he and LaFawnduh ride off across the fields.
Finding Nemo
Disney and Pixar love to include Easter eggs
and references to their other properties in
their movies, but 2003's Finding Nemo had
a cool little Easter egg of that nature after
the credits rolled.
Just after the "special thanks" section started
scrolling on to the screen, none other than
Mike from Monsters, Inc. swam across the screen
and gave a look towards the camera whilst
wearing a diving mask and snorkel.
The idea of Disney and Pixar's characters
inhabiting the same universe often excites
fans, so this particular scene really made
a lot of said fans smile.
Pirates of the Caribbean: On Stranger Tides
The most recent of the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies - 2011's Pirates of the Caribbean:
On Stranger Tides - ended with a post-credits
scene that doesn't bode well for the franchise's
lead character, Johnny Depp's Captain Jack
Sparrow.
The scene shows Angelica - played by Penélope
Cruz - on the island Sparrow had left her
stranded on.
As she sits solemnly by the shore, a voodoo
doll of Sparrow is washed up on the beach.
She picks it up and smirks in a way that suggested
her intentions with the doll could land her
former lover in a spot of trouble.
We will have waited an unprecedented six years,
when 2017's Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead
Men Tell No Tales is released, by the time
we find out if that was indeed the case.
Fast Five
At the start of the previous movie in the
franchise - 2009's Fast & Furious - everyone
was led to believe that Letty, the character
played by Michelle Rodriguez and Vin Diesel's
Dom's former girlfriend, had been murdered.
However, after the credits rolled in 2011's
Fast Five, a major reveal regarding the character
occurred.
Dwayne Johnson's Hobbs is given a file concerning
the hijack of a military convoy in Berlin,
in which he discovers a recent photo of Letty,
revealing that she was actually still alive.
She then went on to reappear in the franchise
in 2013's Fast & Furious 6.
House on Haunted Hill
House on Haunted Hill was a pretty terrible
movie, but it made a pretty bold move with
its post-credits scene.
A lot of horror movies end on a relatively
happy note, with the characters who died going
unmentioned and the surviving characters having
defeated whatever evil was afoot.
House on Haunted Hill, however, opted to show
two of the deceased main characters being
tortured in the afterlife.
The post-credits scene showed Geoffrey Rush's
Steven H. Price and Famke Janssen's Evelyn
Stockard-Price having terrible things done
to them by the ghostly former patients of
the mental asylum that the movie was set in.
This dismal, glum and, frankly, depressing
ending probably contributed towards the absolutely
horrendous reviews received by the movie.
Ferris Bueller's Day Off
The iconic 80's movie Ferris Bueller's Day
Off saw the titular character - played by
Matthew Broderick - breaking the fourth wall
on a number of occasions.
Most notably, this occurred at the beginning
and the end of the movie - and the post-credits
scene was the best example of it.
After the credits had rolled, Ferris emerged
from his bedroom wearing his dressing gown,
expressed surprise that the audience were
still in attendance, and told them to go home
twice, before returning to his room.
Deadpool
In a hilarious throwback to another entry
on this list, 2016's awesome Deadpool movie
had a post-credits scene that paid homage
to Ferris Bueller's Day Off.
Ryan Reynolds' Merc With a Mouth emerged from
the very same bedroom that Ferris Bueller
did in his own post-credits scene - wearing
the exact same dressing gown, no less.
Addressing the audience directly, Deadpool
initially tells them that they don't have
the money to tease any future movies - referencing
Samuel L. Jackson's Iron Man cameo in the
process - before returning to mention the
fact that Cable would be appearing in the
Deadpool sequel.
We simply can't wait for that!
Thanks for watching our list of ten movies
with game changing post credit scenes scenes.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other post credits scenes really made
an impact?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.